I want to thank Rooster Teeth for
allowing us uh time today here in their
Studio space
out here in Austin Texas we are grateful
uh to them and we are grateful for this
space
today's guest is a comedian with a new
special sledge hammer
coming out July 4th uh he is a podcaster
he is the creator of ymh Studios
he is one of a kind and we're grateful
to have him back today Mr Tom Segura
shine
[Music]
[Applause]
looking alive under the Nirvana shirt
was that is that a Nirvana shirt uh no I
think it's a basket
basketball yeah yeah basket
the artist he overdosed oh no all the
good ones
do heroin you know yeah yeah I didn't
know that he had a big collabo with uh
Warhol two heroin addicts going at it
they made some cool I mean it looks like
it looks like drug addicts did it but
yeah yeah I never seen a lot of that
Warhol stuff trying to think of a good
artist that I knew growing up
[Music]
um
I don't know if we had any art
per se in our area really yeah yeah no I
didn't I mean I don't think we had it I
was exposed to a little bit of it I feel
like as a kid and then I had an uncle
who was really into it I think I like it
more as I get older yeah yeah I mean I
do like going into a place like whether
it's someone's home or a business like
people that have art colors popping
you're like oh yeah this is better than
like when do like when you're young and
everything's just like like you have
your apartment it's just White Walls
you're like this is actually like oh
that's why I was depressed
this is a sad place to be and I remember
like girls coming over to Apartments
when I was like in my early 20s and them
being like
there's a serial killer lives here huh
and you're like yeah it's cool right you
don't even think about it you're like
yeah yeah like oh you like that you like
that dateliny Vibe yeah it is kind of
when you look back oh when I look back
on some of the things that I considered
I guess were art or whatever that I
would hang on my wall I remember I got a
jump rope one time and I was so [__]
excited and I like hung that [__] all
along the wall yeah and you're like this
is my [__] yeah people like is this a
rope and people would come in I'd be
like yeah no and then you know what
really does it if you go
even if you just walk into the lobby of
like a nice hotel and you're like oh my
God like where they have like the
bouquet of flowers oh yeah and you're
like oh this snake this like makes
everybody feel calm and kind of like
this what it makes you go is like I want
to be here I want to be in this room yes
colors on the walls and you're like oh
this is nice and then yeah and then you
all of a sudden it hits you years later
where you're like oh I can do a version
of that like I could paint yeah yeah
yeah yeah I could do something to help
out yeah I think I always I've never one
of my friends came in my my home the
other day and he's like dude everything
that's in here is stuff that was in here
when you bought this house like you just
kept this oh there's not yeah and he's
like dude your house it doesn't even
seem like you live here like you have to
start doing something to make this your
home can I tell you I I don't I some
things in life you just realize that you
have to spend the money to do and like I
had to I accepted that I am not a
[__] interior designer but I don't
want
the place to look as sad as those early
Apartments yeah it is the thing you have
to call somebody you just clearly yeah
you just call them and what you do is
they go here's pictures of things and
you go I like this I like this and then
they go like what do you think of this
idea and you're like yeah and then they
just do it wow and you go yeah that's
worth it it was worth it yeah it's worth
it because it's your home so you're
gonna walk in there every time and be
like oh this feels this feels awesome
and it feels like you because you want
it to be things that you pick but you
realize that you're never going to do
that on your own yeah and I mean you
specifically just said that there's [__]
in there that was there like from when
you bought it oh yeah there's a pit
drawings of the previous family was
black ownership and they uh lack of
ownership there's two black yeah there's
like a thing of like a business you're
like there's a black owned [__] car
dealership yeah yeah it's like uh Tulsa
whatever that thing was but it was uh
yeah there's like some
yeah there's people that I don't know on
the walls oh really yeah and so you
bought this place yeah they had left a
few things and you're just like leave it
yeah I just didn't I just never got a
plan I think I just I don't yeah all the
furniture everything that's in there see
the what I would do all the furniture
too oh yeah beds everything wow even
Awards actually that I guess the man who
won a couple of awards what kind of
awards uh first black something or other
you know
so it's like I feel bad keeping that you
know some of them are kind of cool dude
what you got to do is when you you have
somebody help you you know design the
place yeah but in court like have a few
of those like photos or something that
are still from when you got it so it's
mixed in it's all it's all Theo okay but
then when people are like what's up with
this black family you're like those
previous owners yeah yeah yeah you like
do you know them and you're like nah
okay I like to honor them yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I want to have some honor for
them yeah that's all
yeah because it's uh but uh yeah
there'll be nice when I'm grogging I'm
like holy [__] I'm the first black like
you know Commissioner of sure you know
yeah yeah uh when I'm kind of just
wandering around
um
good to see you man good to see you too
man yeah thank you for the uh for coming
and hanging out absolutely I uh
yeah I was trying to think about
um
what was I looking at earlier that I was
thinking about I don't know hmm yeah
just how it is sometimes yeah
it's hot
yeah it's getting harder yeah it just
makes you wanna not think
do you think there's something nice
about like I've lived in places where I
never had air conditioning right yeah
and it's tough but there's also
something that's kind of like
primitive and real about like I feel
like the dreams I had at night were a
little more like yes like I would be
sweating in my sheets does that make any
sense to you a thousand percent a
thousand percent and it's you know the
thing is too is that it's pretty easy to
snap your head back into the hottest
physically hottest most uncomfortable
times in my life like I can actually you
say that and I immediately I go to this
Florida Keys trip I took when I was 14.
and we were down in the keys and it was
hot it was like May June it was hot as
[__] and they had no AC and you just you
just I mean I just literally remember
that I remember doing
um I worked construction for my friends
uh family and we were um the dad had
bought an apartment complex and he
wanted to he had to redo the apartments
so they stripped him down and then we
laid tile and grout in apartments in the
summer in Florida I mean we're talking
like you know it's 100 degrees with 100
humidity and you're on your knees just
like oh and you but there's and there's
no there's not even wind there's just
right but like and you need children for
that labor you definitely do you can't
have actual adults yeah yeah so that was
but like as soon as you say that like
you just I just immediately remember
those moments and then there's something
about like
physically like because you hate it I
mean in the moment you're like I hate
this but you do kind of feel like you're
I don't know you're in a different place
like you're
you really feel like you're working you
really feel like your dreams are yeah
just about air blowing on you that's
like the simplest type of thing yeah or
how like how amazing in those moments is
a cold Gatorade like the you know what I
mean when when you're like you're like
you feel and then somebody goes they
pull it out of a cooler yeah it's like
it was strong and there's nothing
sweeter in the world oh it's so good and
you can't even taste the flavor if
you're constantly have a giveaway I
don't even know you're something like I
don't even know what flavor yeah like
what flavor do you like any of them I
don't know who cares yeah it's like ice
yeah like floral ice or something yeah
bash I'm like that's a flavor that's
insane yeah it's always now it's like
polar plunge and you're like yeah give
it I don't care yeah I don't care what
color [__] and you're like this
tastes this tastes actually pretty
amazing
I didn't realize I wanted a gay bash but
I do that yeah yeah I'll take it on ice
brother yeah that's um yeah those yeah
you could think of like the [__] most
uncomfortable you've ever been hot and
cold I guess yeah cold I never really I
don't think I had too much real coldness
in my life thank God there's people that
are just not as funny like my trainer
mm-hmm he's a you know he's like he's
one of those dudes that is like he just
like they get after it they're
disciplined yes and like he eats right
he works out hard like come on like this
push like go let's you know it's another
one like that's what right that's who
they are they're coaches you know
and the heat he's like I like I like to
be outside when it's 100 and run and
people are like you're gonna [__]
pass like he likes it yeah he wanted
they some people want to go there they
want to go there but the dude has no
tolerance for cold which I find
hilarious you know he like he doesn't
like cold weather he doesn't like the
the cold plunge [__] and like I don't
know it's kind of fun to like catch him
on the other side yeah catch somebody
else yeah yeah yeah yeah like it's cool
and he's just like man I want to get to
a warmer place you see his whole
Personality yeah I love it dude yes I
guess the code really I remember it one
time it snowed in our town and people
had never seen it and people were
yelling [__] at the sky and just yelling
like racial slurs and clouds and [__]
yeah people were
you know like just like these ice
inwards you know just people yelling
[__] outside and some kid went outside
and got hit by an icicle it was like the
first ice that probably ever fell in our
area
and that [__] [__] hit him right in
the cheek and his mom tried to sue the
city sue the City eight years dude it
was this huge thing and she's like Ricky
would have been different and
everybody's like Ricky [__] it was never
different Ricky was always just gonna be
Ricky yeah Ricky was never yeah
yeah Ricky never had a chance you know
Ricky was gonna be a senator or
something like that he was not Ricky was
always going to be cleaning gutters yeah
no chance Ricky was at best gonna be a
drunk driver yeah that's that was like
if he yeah yeah like that's how he got
his name in the paper but
um
dude what was that oh they used to have
those cool things the uh did you ever
see that like they had Evil Knievel
remember those times yeah sure so it was
probably before our time a little bit
but they had
who's this guy uh they had a guy yeah
you know what I'm talking about there we
go this is Jimmy the Greek remember this
[__] dude
off a ramp over 20 motorcycles Jimmy's
gonna attain a speed of 75. Jimmy the
Greek I think
so stupid that's so stupid and I love it
we don't even get to do [__] like this
anymore look at the actual fell off yeah
[Applause]
and look they're going to rescue him
dude you gotta let this guy can you
imagine just telling somebody about your
accomplishments dude like who are you
like I [__] I jumped over 20
motorcycles in a school bus oh wow
that's you yeah
dude would they there's so much Kickback
from that when the front nose hit the
ramp I think it
I mean that's [__] cool dude
God it was funny you ever ride the bus
to school oh yeah of course by the way
is there more than one Jimmy the Greek
my is that the Jimmy the Greek that we
all know
you know what I mean the commentary
that's a flying Greek this guy because
this is Jimmy the flying grease ah okay
very I was like there's no way that that
guy yeah there was the other guy that
was a commentary Snyder okay yeah this
guy yeah I'm like this [__] guy's
driving the bus
like that would be crazy oh yeah he got
busted for what yeah I think it was a
racial thing right it wasn't it um
it was a lot it was 70s or eight it was
yeah racial comments and dismissal 1988.
oh yeah oh he said yeah that people were
bred to be in better shape Superior
athletes yeah the black is not a good
way to start a sentence the black is a
better athlete to begin with yeah this
guy's out of his mind yeah I mean he's
on point I mean he's definitely right
but you don't say it like yeah yeah you
gotta pretend like you don't think that
yeah or you just don't say it but what
about you see guys like isn't it so
great to picture him driving that bus
yeah
like you're like that it actually looks
like a bus driver oh yeah dude bro we
had a guy in our neighborhood named
Milford right and this dude never had a
shirt or he couldn't be in a shirt
something was wrong with him
and he would drive us [__] with no
shirt sometimes and sometimes he
wouldn't even take us to school and the
police would all come pick us up off the
bus really take us into their cars yeah
that reminds me of uh Ariel Castro
remember him
that's the guy that kidnapped those
three girls and kept them in a basement
in Cleveland oh yeah there was a huge
National story he was a bus driver in
Cleveland OH and one time before he got
caught up before this whole thing
exploded he just got mad and left the
kids on the bus and just abandoned the
bus
and he did he uh he was suspended that
was it he was suspended for a year but
this this dude
was a was a this could this guy was
driving kids to school
probably just picking out the best ones
interviewing them for years at a time
yeah he was like all right come back
we'll talk again next week real [__]
psycho I wouldn't want to have anybody
kidnapped in my house I don't think
especially three people oh
well at least if you have you know they
say if you have goats you shouldn't have
just one
yeah that is a good point yeah my mother
was gonna we were gonna get my mother a
goat and then
when she found out she had to have two
goats she's like I don't want two goats
yeah I want one yeah but one will they
get so sad that they can't stand
themselves yeah I don't think Ariel was
thinking like that but he was um yeah he
was a real he was a real [__] bag of a
human being for sure
it was crazy to watch him I remember
when the story it was such a it was such
an unbelievable story because he had
them for years yeah and he was such a
psycho that he would um
he would join the search parties oh like
when they would have uh annual like he
would go with those and then he would go
back and tell the girls like people are
still looking for you and laugh and
stuff like he was real wonderful when
they were walking down the street he was
like you're getting warm
right insane or if like they start to
walk up to his place he's like I would
take a left here yeah
nope just check this place yeah he's
just [__] doing stuff like that and
he had you know the funny thing is like
the way that like the human mind works
is that
he the one that he trusted there's the
three and the one that he trusted and he
had a baby with when oh yeah he was
there and so he
so trusted how fearful they were that he
would leave her like Unchained and free
she was so brainwashed and scared that
yeah she would just stay until the day
that she didn't but she never
it was pretty wild man but he was um
it's like Bert and Arby's I feel like
yeah that's exactly what it is that's
exactly what it is I feel like it's like
he would stay in there he'll he will
never leave that roast beef is like it's
it's like a girl in his basement
[Music]
roast beef and him are one how
interesting that bird has made his own
sound in the world how many people have
made their own sound that's a really
good point you're doing it yeah
yeah who started that type of school
yeah
and he he's so I think you can only make
that sound if you enjoy yourself that
much he's so pleased with himself I've
never met somebody who is so enamored
with themselves like yeah and then he'll
be like I understand that like you know
people get exhausted of me and I'm like
oh really he goes unless
you like me then you can't get enough
and I'm like Jesus Christ
he's like and I'm like which one are you
he's like I definitely can't get enough
of me oh my God like how do you have
this much love for yourself he's got to
enjoy it that's true huh he probably
wakes up every day and he's like yeah
I'm awesome a bird again it's funny
because everybody usually struggles with
the other side of that yeah right like
I'm not good enough he doesn't huh I
mean I don't think like well maybe but
it's like it's so morphed into this
other thing or like with bodies like
everybody who you know it goes like ah
you know I wish I didn't have this belly
or like you know and then he's just like
I look [__] great yeah like wait what
like you're focusing on the wrong thing
which is what like like a psychologist
would tell you it'd be like you know
look at your great shoulders and then
they'd be like oh okay yeah and then
he's just like yeah I automatically do
that I look [__] great and you're
like okay uh all right I was yeah I was
wrong like I was looking at you and
actually picking everything apart but
yeah you do have nice nice delts
yeah you have legs like a snowman yeah
these little pencil legs I guess I was
looking pretty crazily yeah man yeah
that is interesting man yeah you know I
think he has an infallible and I don't
know what that means but he has like
this ability to
he has a [__] under his there's
something about him that's unfucking
defeated yeah well it seems like anyway
I mean you know him so well well it
you're right you're right it is it's um
it's that ultimately he he he really
buys into I'm gonna bet on myself in
every aspect I believe in myself
and he's not gonna wallow in like the
any of the negative stuff oh yeah you
know he's somebody like and that's also
something that you would be taught like
just keep moving forward that's that's
him all times he's going going I think
almost to his own detriment we're like
you need to go like like like hold back
pull back a little bit right be present
in this because I think he's just like
the race is over but he's still going
he's still yeah yeah that's that's
exactly what he's doing he's still
running and they're like is this is over
right now yeah you can then yeah he just
goes and goes and goes but it's
interesting he um you know he gets like
it's funny because people just see like
uh a shirtless
morbidly obese lunatic yeah and they go
this guy's a [__] this guy gambles
yeah he's a mess
um and he is all those things but he's
actually you know I say he's actually a
lot smarter than he gets credit for
because it's easy to go this guy is just
a dope and he's drunk yeah but he's he's
actually like I I mean I'm honest like
seriously he as far as ideas too like
creatively he's an idea man dude and and
I don't think people give him any credit
like he busts out ideas
you could go if you went up to him and
you're like I wish I I want to have a
television show
he would throw you give you an idea 10.
wow he'll throw you 10. and then you're
like I don't like that one I don't like
that one that one's and then you'll be
like whoa that's
I think that's the best idea I've heard
for that it's a good one yeah he really
is hmm Le esta gustando Me podcast
that is Spanish for are you liking my
podcast that's Spanish and Babel is how
you can
figure one in the other out that's
Babble the language learning app
it'll help you with Spanish that's for
sure
you can learn it there with Babel you
can start speaking a new language
in just three weeks a new language
here's another one
podcast
and that is uh German or German for how
do you like my podcast right there they
can do it
with over 10 million subscriptions sold
Babel is real language learning for real
conversations if you're going to be
sitting around doing nothing you can be
learning another language maybe you want
to adopt a kid the kid is
um Norwegian you don't know how to say
hey we want to adopt you you can learn
Babel will help you meet the kid here's
a special limited time deal for our
listeners to get you started right now
get 55 off with your Babel subscription
at Babel
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Theo that's 55 off
at
babel.com
t-h-e-o spelled babel.com Theo rules and
restrictions May apply this episode is
brought to you by betterhelp
you gotta know that
if you're if you're sitting there right
now and
and you're listening to this and there's
something uncomfortable in your life
there's something you can't tell anyone
there's something that keeps popping
into your head and it's really causing
you a lot of discomfort or or pain
if you're if you're just you don't know
what's going on with you if you're
having a tough time those are anyway
those are reasons in the past where I've
uh sought to seek help
and better help
can do that for you that's right
uh it's easy to get caught up with a new
professional if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule
that's right therapy can help give you
tools to to better deal with your own
life just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge find more
balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com
Theo to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
betterhelp.com Theo
yeah you know sometimes you see there's
only a couple things you can see you
don't even see people's other you don't
you don't get a chance maybe other
things overshadow them
you know you don't get to know him in
other regards I think that a lot about a
lot of the UFC fighters some of them are
so cool at other [__] are so funny or
whatever yeah you never even get to know
because they're just seen as like this
Warrior well because it's easy it's all
of us want to go that's who this is yeah
and it's easy to Define people as
one-dimensional yeah you know like like
Theo's a southern guy and he's a
comedian and like I don't that's all you
are and you should like I want to be
able to describe him in this way yeah
you know I don't I don't if you told me
he likes sailing and skeet shooting it
doesn't add up so I'm not gonna they
don't wanna they don't want to hear it
they just want to hear like this is who
he is who he is and it's and it make it
simple and let me and it's it's like
when somebody goes um
somebody says they like guns they go oh
so you're like a conservative right-wing
Second Amendment champion and someone
was like I don't know what the [__]
you're talking about I just like going
to the shooting like you know yeah
you're like I'm just a tech nine fan or
something yeah exactly but but like so
many people go well that does if you
like this then you are this type of
person yeah and what the truth is that
like a UFC fighter can like the ballet
you know like it just doesn't but a lot
of people just don't want to think
outside of what is comfortable because
then it might shatter everything that
they believe oh that's true yeah man
because they don't want to think that
somebody that a redneck guy could have a
black buddy that really that is that
he's not afraid to do sleepovers with
exactly exactly because they would
[__] ruin their whole ball of wax
exactly and then they don't get to be
lazy thinkers because that's essentially
it's being lazy to go I I want to easily
Define everybody with like oh he's from
here he's this type of guy got it that's
what he is yeah
yeah that's interesting man I got to
keep tabs on my brain sometimes I'm
going to trust to do that because Yeah
because sometimes we all do we all do
yeah but then sometimes it's also fun if
you're joking around it's a stereotype
and yeah you have to be able to do it of
course I mean I think of like these uh
Like Comics like Brian Simpson you know
Brian he's so funny and what I love is
that he challenges what people will like
will think yeah because they want to
Define them you know like they go like
oh he's black yeah he seems like maybe
like a bus driver's son or whatever but
they go like oh he served in the
military so then somebody will be like
well he's he's my guy and then you go
and you talk to him and then you realize
no but he also he he has left-leaning
thoughts and ideas he has he's a blood
donor he's a blood donor even bone
marrow he'll go that far oh God and then
but like he's the thing is like you
can't easily just Define them you can't
because the guy is an original thinker
he has you know he has moderate thoughts
he has left because he's a like
everybody he's a multi-layered complex
individual yeah and as a like from an
audience standpoint when you watch a guy
like that that's fun because you go well
he he if he was ex-military he must be
like this he's like not yeah and his
ideas are just original you know and I
love that he challenges people's idea of
what he's supposed to be yeah
do you think uh yeah Brian is a really
unique dude he's interested in here I
like how he's kind of a little bit
patient with it you know it's like he's
kind of that silent killer he's like
emphysema oh yeah he is exactly
emphysema yeah yeah because and that
takes like real skill yeah yeah yeah and
years of smoking like you you don't just
get there like that's confidence and you
got to be good honestly if you take your
time people who take their time are
the most fun to watch I think yeah yeah
that's a good statement oh that Ron
White had this great I think he was he
told Christina this he goes don't easily
just remember
if you're
you're if you're doing bad up there
slow down if you're doing good up there
slow down
like across the board right drop it down
a notch right because everybody's
Instinct a lot of times is like speed up
speed like faster more and then you get
it on both sides because you're like
you're like yeah if I'm dying up there I
want to get like let's just go maybe I
can run through this and I won't suffer
as badly yeah and if you're killing it's
almost like this level of excitement you
want to keep the gasket it's like just
slow down
did you ever get in moments where I've
found like even looking back on some
shows where it's like man I was in such
a pattern of doing my material that that
becomes almost a not a problem but it
becomes something I have to contend with
each show like how do I not make this
feel original to my face to my through
everything absolutely I mean I call it
um press play performing when you get
into the pattern so much that it's like
you press play on yeah on the you know
on your remote yeah because like right
here and right now you're gonna be right
here here's the show and you just do the
show yeah the great thing is that you
you have the ability to recognize that
it's happening and the first what
happens first I think is that you're
you're out there doing a show after show
after show
you go what is going on then you realize
oh I'm like I'm stale I'm bored and I'm
doing the same [__] show beat by beat
and even like like you said facial like
I turn my face here and I do this and I
gesture like this and it's hitting the
mark and it's it's bad it's bad for you
yeah and so you start the the first
thing I try to do is go I'm gonna I have
to open that the next show differently
whether it's a a joke from the act that
I moved to the front or I'm gonna riff
at the front or I'm gonna I'm gonna
write a new like I have to start
differently because sometimes if you
start the show like completely
differently it gives you this this
energy for the rest of the show like
this whole this something inside you
changes I really think the key to all of
it is that
when you're in that zone of doing the
same [__] you have to challenge yourself
to create something new yeah because
there's no juice like that there's
nothing that feels better oh yeah than a
new thing but it's also work that you
don't have to do so that's why it's a
challenge because you're like I have the
the show works right it'll be fine it'll
be fine without me doing that but it's
the only way to get through that feeling
of like this sucks right now I'm not
having fun yeah and there's a little
other element that happens there's some
other magic in the room whenever the if
you can get that freshness somehow it's
like it's it the right word for it is
Magic because there's no other way to
like you can only say it to other people
who have done it but I just remember
that like when I was touring Europe
I was I just written some new stuff and
then I opened the show and like
you start with such a pop of but it's a
fresh pop because this is my new toy
like yeah you just you that I was
performing the rest of the show with
such a level of like excitement and I
and then I would get off and the people
that like the tour crew would be like
they're like man you're having like so
much fun there and you're like yeah and
you know why because of the first five
minutes yeah that carried me through the
through the hour yeah and then there's
like
you realize in those moments you're like
well anytime I feel stale
what I need to do is that I need to like
try something new yeah that's what it is
you know it's and like it kind of
applies to life too right people who get
like oh I'm bored I'm like you gotta try
that's true yeah if you're bored if
you're with your spouse in the bedroom
if you're bored with your buddy and
you're just sitting somewhere you got to
order a toy yeah you gotta work yeah
yeah yeah you gotta turn on the the
thing that like it goes around under
like it it it's like cinches the top of
your ball bag and then there's the other
part on your on your dick and so you
have two clamps going down oh I mean
that'll change you and your friends yeah
dude like relationship yeah for sure
you and that black guy they're doing the
sleepover yeah you're gonna have the
best night
dude I remember one of the first times I
realized that black and white people
were different when we were riding in a
truck in the back of a truck somewhere
and our basketball coach was taking us
somewhere to probably do work for him
for free because he was kind of like
that and
um he my we got to a stop sign we've
been going like 50 miles an hour and my
black buddy this kid uh Mike
um
he go what's it like to have your hair
Blow In The Wind that's what he asked me
yeah that's a good one I was like wow
it's interesting it takes you a second
right you're like what and then you're
like oh yeah
yours just kind of moves all together
yeah it was just saying yeah you got a
dent in your [__] right now yeah yeah
dude yeah you have like a [__] Twigs
you need to go see someone to reset
everything yeah
um yeah I'm trying to think of what else
has been interesting going on
did you guys you got enough Fitness a
lot recently huh yeah I mean on this on
the last tour you know what happened was
that like
I always
like do it somewhat right because you
guys have done that uh sober October for
a while but even like before that it was
always like I mean that would be a
another time but I would get like to a
certain point and then I would have the
mentality of like oh
I I got there like it's almost like the
race is over like I'm done like now I'm
good
like 10 times or more and so that what
happens is you when you go like I'm done
you just kind of retreat back to old
habits and you get out of shape
and then also you're like oh [__] how'd
this happen again and then you you go
I'm gonna do it again and then you go
all right I'm gonna work out and eat
clean and then you lose weight and you
start to get and then you go oh I did I
got to this number again all right I
feel and then you just kind of pull back
yeah so it really was that I got
frustrated by that and I had this I had
I had gotten I was I was on tour
and um we were working out on tour but
not really like
dialed in on food which and the tour was
like aggressive like Non-Stop
and I remember that I got to back to LA
to shoot this thing I was shooting this
pilot
I had written and I I was I was covering
the whole production and I went I
remember I was in the uh the Wardrobe
fitting for it and I was like [__] this
is like I feel like I'm going back like
in in the fitting the clothes I was like
oh this sucks and then I left there like
after that week and I was like I have to
take this more seriously but the
difference is is that I no longer go if
I see
a number that I like on a scale that
means I'm good it's just I I realized
that you have to do it like that there
is no end there's right it's just
continuous right it's like it's
something that you just if it's about
goals you just have to set new goals you
know like if you you can't go like oh if
I see this number I'm I'm at the weight
I like okay you have to set new fitness
goals like you have to go well this
month is about ah you know like cardio
stuff or this month I want to see if I
can do 200 push-ups a day like you have
to set goal that's what I I mean that's
so that's what happened for you had you
been doing that before in your life
setting like I mean I know we have
sometimes subconsciously we set goals we
don't realize and we have some of that
going on in our general life but have
you ever done it that specifically
before we were like I'm gonna set a goal
uh I've kind of loosely I would say you
know like hey this month let's go let's
go after this type of thing and yeah
things like like in sober October but
this was also the time where I was like
you know this really as like cliche as
it sounds can be like a lifestyle change
and now I realized how much I am
affected not just physically mentally
emotionally by and in a good way by my
like working out a lot and like waking
up
getting my my stuff together going to
the gym right away and I'm like I'm just
having a better day I'm just happier
yeah I'm moving around better I look
better I feel like so I just go
I feel like I have better uh creative
days you know like it's all kind of tied
together yeah it's it's tied together so
I just made it like
part of what I do it's like you know I
just I I know that I want to eat certain
types of food that are good for me and
by the way I'm not saying this like I am
the most strict dude and don't ever like
but I'm just like there's just so much
more oh yeah clean eating yeah and um
and I like that I like the workouts I
like it you know I like being active and
I just feel like
I'm very fortunate in that I have a
full-time trainer so yeah I know I'm I'm
not right not everybody has that I
totally understand that it's a huge
Advantage so sometimes people will be
like well yeah of course you can do that
if you I'm like yeah that's I'm I'm very
lucky that I can do it but you also just
have to want that in your life yeah and
uh well even having a buddy that goes
with you to the gym that used to be one
of the funnest times when I was young
dude we would go and we used to do
steroids back in the day and really what
kind of steroids would you do oh dude
test 200 400
we might have did a [__] 1100 they
came out with for like [__] a couple
weeks I got I take some tests though do
you what are you are you with vitamin C
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah like a couple
Jabs yeah were you doing the butt cheek
yeah yeah it's almost gets kind of fun I
hate to say that but see I take a
moderate dose though right I I was like
oh man this is gonna be wild and they're
like not with what we give you oh yeah
like they're like like one of the guys
was like oh he's like how much you take
it and I told him he goes that ain't
[__] he goes I would take three times
that amount in a in one session I was
like what but he was also a bodybuilder
yeah I was like yeah I mean that's not
I'm not trying to do that you know yeah
yeah I just want to be
recover more and yeah and it makes me I
remember well I took I also tried a
testosterone that was like I saw on the
internet you know I fell into one of
those deals one night and you know I
bought like a couple weird shirts on
Facebook and next you know I'm buying
like tests some from some companies
mailing it right yeah yeah and they
mailed it with like some ice in like a
[__] like that that's what you know
[__] is a little weird when they're
mailing you all the needles and the ice
and stuff oh yeah yeah
um and I tried that for a while made
some of my hair fall out really yeah I
noticed that that was a bad side effect
from it which was a little scary was it
affecting aggression people always talk
about Roid Rage and [__] like was you
were you snap it made me want to hump no
yeah it made me want to [__] hump
dude I'll [__] a mailman I felt like a
damn doll you know yeah really oh God I
found myself running to the edge of the
fence if the male guy would drive off
I had a guy a friend of mine that was in
college it was juicing and the way that
he would snap after a while I was like
yo like this guy's about to [__] rip
somebody's arm out of itself yeah he was
and I was like oh okay I'm seeing this
firsthand it was it was pretty nutty you
know you just [__] yeah all the time
I was like holy [__] oh there was
nothing like juicing back in the day
dude my buddy and I met this fellow's a
homosexual and he was a uh prize fighter
right and nobody knew he was he was just
like he'd grown up fighting and then so
then people would just think he was gay
and around then he'd beat the [__] out
of somebody that's a [__] perfect
combo it was an insane combo right
people weren't ready for like you're
saying like people want to put you in
one box if you're a fighter you can't be
gay yeah I've never had seen it yeah so
um so we became buddies we're both bus
boys and we became buddies and we
started shooting up and we'd pull over
on the side of the interstate and stuff
like that and just douse each other up
and we're just driving around just
um it was right around when Princess
Diana had died too and it was just a
[__] lot but I remember we would do a
bunch of steroids and I remember the
first day I was in class where I guess
the teacher had given me like every
quarter she had this stack of papers and
she would turn them all back to the
students she gave me the stack and I'd
had this stack before and it was usually
kind of heavy in my hands yeah and I
just remember like she gave me the stack
and I was like isn't that funny you
remember remember the weight of it yeah
that this is like oh this is light this
light work baby yeah this is light work
dude yeah so I remember walking around
with this stack and I was like oh I'm a
[__] different guy yeah it's a good
feeling and then I was doing all kind of
[__] and I would buy [__] that wasn't
even steroids that people would tell me
it was and I was [__] a diarrhea for
like three months one time horribly I
put some I mean there's still some stuff
I took some kind of oil like I think
some illegal oils or whatever there was
some things that I wish I hadn't taken
you know probably but at that time were
it was so rare to get it one time
somebody we all went to Mexico for
um
school year thing or something end of
school and people bought it back in
shampoo bottles so then you were [__]
doing this sudsy bubbly [__] really
yeah like you felt like slippery all the
time but you were still doing it I wish
I I remember being scared to try in high
school yeah and there was a couple dudes
that were doing it in high school which
I thought was like because that back
then from like all you'd heard was like
uh Lyle Alzado when he died yeah and
you're like hey steroids and I was like
oh steroids are like the worst and then
there's a couple of kids like 16 year
old kids you know on steroids and one of
them looked like a [__] like it looked
like a bodybuilder like he had a man's a
muscular man's body and you kind of were
like that would be [__] pretty nice
this guy's like I mean just [__] yeah
but I still was like now if I do that
I'll die like that's what I thought you
know like I so I just I wouldn't do it
and then this dude went to college and
got on
I saw him on a break and I was like I
mean he looked like a gorilla I was like
wow what are you he's like they got me
on this [__] called Darth Vader and I
was like that's yeah I see it like yeah
like if I [__] see it dude he was
[__] so jacked I remember he went to
Florida State and yeah that was J that
was that nature remember they had that
movie that came out about Florida State
yeah yeah they were doing the drugs man
yeah I think there was something that
was definitely it was big it was big to
get if you can get on some roids and
then like yeah you would get a girl who
was like always just afraid you were
gonna beat or some of those women you
know like perfect girlfriend yeah yeah
like she'd be like don't beat me she'd
write that at the end of every like love
letter or whatever and you hadn't even
thought about it yeah you know but they
get your wheels turned she sees what you
do to tables and windows and [__] she's
like oh [__] yeah yeah yeah dude there
was a couple times where I [__]
snapped man where you would be shocked
at some of your own behaviors you know
and then your strength matches your
anger and you're just able to do
something insane you know were you doing
like traditional lifts when you were
juicing too like bench squat deadlift
that kind of stuff yeah a lot of that
some rows where you hit crazy crazy
numbers on them I probably got to maybe
two
60 maybe I could bench 245 or 260 which
isn't insane but for me it was sure
um squats I did okay but I definitely
remember and I never thought I looked
okay so I really had some deficiency
with my own brain yeah I was always like
do I seem okay I'd be embarrassed to
take my shirt off at places you didn't
have that Burt mentality at all no the
unlimited [__] like
I feel like Bert should just turn his
stomach get a nipple put on his just
make a third tip you know it's it's
almost there like the biggest hit like
the winner tip yeah this is the main tip
yeah yeah dude yeah bro how sick
he's got two nipples and then like a
little curtain and he pulls it over yeah
and it's like the unveiling yeah God I
saw a lady last night with the craziest
hits really good or bad or risk ass wait
it was just you know when there's so
there they were such
outrageous hits like she was hot and
they were enormous and she was wearing
the uh you know the like the top that
goes here but the top was just above the
nipples so I mean just just yeah just a
covering like you could almost see the
beginning of a nipple and they were like
here and then she has this little body
and party just wants to go like hey
just why don't you just take a moment in
the room and just go hey everybody
get used to them yeah like why are we
going to pretend like we're gazing past
right yeah like I kept having to pretend
I was like what's what's that noise over
there I wasn't looking at a [__]
noise looking at your crazy tits your
tits are insane yeah is that an owl yeah
and then guys are like talking to me
about other things I go we're gonna talk
about her tits first like what are you
doing
and they're like oh yeah I'm like what
do you think we're gonna like gloss over
this like her tits are out she has huge
tits that are out in the room
yeah it is weird not to just bring it up
it's like when someone's in a wheelchair
and they try to pretend they're not
enough God please like and tell me some
[__] how do you go to the bathroom yeah
you know like I want to know or like
almost hit my head on that door frame
it's like no you did no you didn't yeah
give me a couple lines about what it's
like I'm gonna tell you [__] like I'm
gonna be like hey let's race like let's
have a little fun with this [__] get
weird yeah
we had uh who came out oh uh The
Undertaker came out to the show last
night ah dude which is pretty crazy dude
I went to his house yes I think it Hardy
has a beautiful Army he was just
describing some of it not like in a
braggy way just saying that they lived
here he is
did you talk to him for a while yeah
really nice the nicest like one of the
nicest guys I've ever met him and his
wife and she had some bangers on her and
I shouldn't say that out loud I mean
this is a damn Undertaker we're talking
to who works for death where was it is
this at the uh this at the Paramount at
the Paramount yeah uh you had Ron there
too yeah it was nice man that's awesome
man that Ron looks great for I mean Ron
is like
48.
I think he's a little older he looks
[__] great he looks great that head
of hair too God you almost want to
[__] scalp him yeah you do you might
get there you might have that one day
we'll see man a full head of white hair
is pretty [__] cool dude I would love
that he is the coolest no I went over to
uh
to it's so crazy to say The Undertaker's
house and uh
and like he was like come on it it was
just to uh check out a piece of workout
equipment okay and the people that I was
talking to I was like I'd like to
they're like do you want this thing I go
I'd like to try it before I go I want
this thing yeah and then they go well we
could like I have a another client that
you know I go okay
and then they just like in the text
they're like hey Tom this Mark he has it
and I was like what's up Mark
and then like a separate text came in
they're like just so you know Mark is
the Undertaker I was like oh okay good
to know uh
and then I just go over there and he
just couldn't be like more gracious he's
wearing an apron and everything I mean
yeah he's like here's a muffin he was
just like no but he he was like so and
then he was just like yeah try whatever
you want and gave us like the full tour
and then he was like well it was a real
pleasure meeting you and I was like same
yeah and then later on I go thanks a lot
for uh you know allowing us and he sent
like
the the most like the most gracious text
of like uh it was a absolute pleasure to
welcome you into my home I was like oh
that's nice [__] is this man like this
is wild but death will sneak you like
that too that's what death would do
that's true it kind of taunt you yeah
yeah it seduce you yeah yeah so maybe I
should watch out I mean around Mark yeah
because if people bat on you or burnt to
die people would go bird huh
of course yeah of course
it looks worse every day but I wonder
what a parlay would he'd be like yeah I
just feel like coated red
you know growing had his head it keeps
growing which is crazy his head is
swelling yeah that's part of me smart
money but then like that guy that owns
that mattress company he'd be like I'm
gonna put 10 million on top
that guy lives in Texas you guys should
get that guy like who's gonna die he'd
be like a thousand percentile
because the vet's gonna take for it'd
probably be a d at least a semi-decent
amount of time yeah that's true he's too
old for that pet I think I don't know
it'd be interesting I mean Bert could if
you bet the underarm Bert I think he
could you could see some money this you
know yeah you could see some money by
but yeah that MRI on Bert must just come
back oh [__] like the first part is
appetizers you're like how is this this
that I remember his appetizer he was
doing the thing that people do who are
you know who don't live healthy and are
scared which he was like avoiding
um like blood work and stuff oh yeah I
was like dude you got to do it
he's avoiding avoiding and then he did
it and you could see like he was like
fidgeting and [__] and you're like what
is going on he's like she's waiting for
the phone call about my blood work I
don't know and then you're like oh [__]
like this you know and I honestly like
all joking aside you could be like
you're like this might be like a serious
call you get right
and like then I just he facetimes me and
he's like what's up bro and I was like
what's going on he's like just got off
the phone everything's [__] great I
was like wait what and he was like the
doctor told me to go celebrate with a
drink I go your doctor says that like
what kind of doctor is this did you meet
them at a strip mall like he's like he's
like I'm good to go and I was like I
don't know man I'm gonna give you the
number of another doctor
yeah he was just like celebrating good
blood work I was like there's a Baskin
Robbins yeah
drink it up tonight
so yeah that's interesting dude you know
the sun can get you sometimes you see
somebody and their their eyes are
missing
and you say well dang what happened in
the sun got in them
they got too much sun in their eyes and
they just
dies can't handle it and they leave
they leave the body but our friends at
Shady Ray's have you covered
for the warm weather and bright sunlight
ahead
with premium polarized Shades at an
affordable price that's right Shady Rays
is an independent sunglasses company
that offers a world-class product that's
as good as any expensive pair we've ever
worn
and I lose the expensive ones anyway
and if you lose or break your pair even
on day one they told us they will send
you a brand new pair no questions asked
that's right where your shady Rays with
confidence because they have your back
long after you purchase
exclusively for our listeners Shady Rays
is giving out their best deal of the
Season go to shadyraise.com and use code
Theo for 50 off two or more pairs of
polarized sunglasses that's right try
for yourself the shades rated five stars
by over 250 000 people cold turkey
might be good on sandwiches but there's
a better way to break your bad habits
that's right we're not talking about
some weird mind voodoo from your crazy
neighbor or some Seance or Seance say
or whatever I'm talking about fume
fume is an Innovative award-nominated
device that helps you break your bad
habit
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural instead of vapor fume
uses flavored air and instead of harmful
chemicals fume uses all natural
delicious flavors you get it
instead of bad fume is good it's a habit
you're free to enjoy and makes replacing
your bad habit easy that's right fume
tastes good it's more flavorful than you
thought and it feels fresh
that's one thing that I like
they're made out of real wood if you
like wood it could be Birch it could be
Ma mahagani
mahogany
you'll feel cool using it
stopping is something we've all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over 100 000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason one of them can't be you join
fume and accelerating Humanity's breakup
from destructive Habits by picking up
the journey pack Take Me Home Tonight
I don't know if that's Journey or not
but the journey pack today had to
tryfume.com and use code Theo to save 10
off when you get the journey pack today
that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code Theo to
save an additional 10 off your order
today
do you remember the first hit you ever
saw as a child and how it went out how
it
first I ever saw
no I mean I you know what I do remember
is and this is really
it's sad that I feel like
this generation doesn't won't just can't
really experience this unless they make
like a concerted effort
is that there used to be just like such
an excitement around a woman in a bikini
oh yeah or um if you just saw a breast
like just a nude woman you were like wow
right and then you realize that
like like if you wanted obviously to see
something like hardcore you really had
to make a real effort yeah and now like
you know you pick up people have their
like pornography libraries in their
pocket
and so like that excitement that chase
yeah is like they're they're they're
their bar for it is so elevated which I
think is kind of sad yeah really you
know they don't realize that like just
like the idea
of sex the fantasy of it would be like
enough for a long time and then you're
exposed to things where you're like whoa
[__] and that's when it starts like
that's when like you could really make a
knock on that it's bad to have access to
anything and everything
um I remember seeing like
erotic art and being like oh this is
actually pretty cool there's like these
really great accounts on Instagram and
you realize if you like if you see them
you're letting your mind do this thing
yeah and it's actually pretty cool I
think it's it's actually a much
healthier oh yeah thing to do I really
like a lot of myself with pornography
it's yeah I mean like I I I'm very
careful when I say it because I I never
like to
um bash them no like I I feel like
they're
they're you know I know people in that
industry it's a great industry it's a
lot of great people there's a lot of
great people in there but I do feel like
there's like anything everything
requires some some balance yeah and like
you can go overboard on anything on food
on drinking and definitely on
pornography or something and yeah I just
feel like it's it's much better for you
if you're young I would be like you know
if you're in that age where you want to
like explore that and you're when I say
young I just mean like you know oh yeah
you know you're getting into your sexual
exploration like man try erotic art and
see what it does for your brain like let
your brain tell you stories yeah because
just like having this access to and like
just your search words and just seeing
it play out it's like what'll happen is
like it's actually it's not a theory
your brain starts to with time reduce
the dopamine levels that you're feeling
like you get a dopamine drip from that
stuff but because all you have to do is
type in what you like
then when you see it you're like oh
here's a little less right and then the
next search you get a little less of it
and then pretty soon
the thing that was exciting to you it
doesn't even give you a thrill that's
why you hear people they go ahead and
raise the stakes to add raises and they
just keep raising and getting crazier
with it getting weird because it's too
like if it's too easy to access you're
not going to feel the excitement you're
not going to feel the rush I mean when
we were like coming up as like teens and
stuff I mean oh Peep and tommen was
popping ah dude you're just like
sister's friends would come over and
just just just seeing them lay around
like by the pool or like just hang out
in the watching a television on the
couch you would be like this is the most
exciting thing that's ever happened oh
yeah dude I remember a girl asked me to
hold her necklace while she swam one
time and I [__] masturbated like
three times oh yeah yeah because I just
had never even held something of a
woman's for a while I totally understand
I remember going to some girl's birthday
party or something and she invited like
all the kids in the class or whatever
and like we would all like run into her
sister's room and like try to find her
Underpants and stuff and like I remember
something you know how older is this I
might have been kind of like we
shouldn't be in here you know he was
still like just being kids and like
I remember hiding in my buddy's hamper
at his house just to smell his mother's
bras
and I'd hide in there for a [__] hour
and just Huff those cups I bet that
smells God it just [__] do you still
remember that smell I remember the
collar of the hamper it was like a green
color they don't even make anymore yeah
it was like an old green almost like the
color of The Wonder Years car like the
car that they had it was like an old
kind of pukish green almost
that they wouldn't even mark it anymore
and it was just God but it's just like
see those are just
little moments yeah but now it's just
like you put in something next thing you
know and I think nowadays by the time
you're 17 you don't even care about sex
you're like seeing it all you have no
that's no fun it's not good for you it's
horrible yeah it's horrible what else do
we got anything and then
thing in the news that
yeah we're looking at this the uh the
world's dirtiest man died oh I remember
this guy I didn't yeah this is actually
is that black face or not
it's a little bit
I mean
he has not bathed with water or soap for
over 60 years wow yeah read that caption
I guess he he would smoke a pipe filled
with animal excrement and he believed
that cleanliness would make him ill
dude that's pretty interesting
because maybe cleanliness is what kill
is is what's killing us
too much too much so like if you think
about in the history of human beings
it's only in the last I mean not even
100 years less than that think it's
probably in the last like
I don't know
60 or something years that
that human beings were like hey every
day maybe twice a day right with autism
too they're saying yeah like a lot of
autism could be called by uh caused by
metals and different soaps and things
like that yeah because this dude doesn't
look like he has autism uh from this
photo I can't tell but he um I remember
seeing this dirty I mean I wonder too do
you think there's just a level where you
just stop smelling like you know I mean
like a couple weeks in you're like you
smell like [__] man right yeah but then
after like I don't know 30 years you're
just probably like yeah it just kind of
evens out right yeah yeah yeah like he
maybe doesn't I bet you he tastes real
bad but I bet you the smell just kind of
it hit a level that your butt it's just
trying to tell you a signal stay away
from this yeah dude when people can
plant things on your back
that's probably a crazy time for
somebody you know I wonder what I'd want
to be the world's wettest man did you
ever have a uh Guinness book of record
did you ever have a record you wanted to
try and get even something small to you
you're so fascinated by that for there's
an age group where you're like an age
range oh I was in that well that was the
biggest when that book came out at the
book fair whatever it was like oh dude
somebody did this remember the Chinese
kids all hanging off the bicycle yeah it
was like one guy had like 40 Chinese
people on his bike there's so many weird
now they're even like
they're so insane I remember and also
it's funny my seven-year-old uh has the
uh because they release books now of it
like each year he's like fascinated by
it just like oh the world record yeah
but I was watching their their account
and this was I was like okay this this
shows you where it's at now it was
the guy attempting to break the world
record
for the most pine needles broken at one
time
and so he was hanging from like by his
by one hand and he's jumping into a box
of pine needles and you're like you guys
are crediting this but that's when
you're that's when you're like I just
need to be in the book I just want to be
you know yeah but and that makes you
realize that we could definitely just
come up with one where they'll be like
yeah there's no record for that yet yeah
like I mean dude you and bertia get a
Guinness record we should get a record
you're right that is true it's got to be
a tandem thing it would be interesting
yeah I feel like I could see you guys
getting something very unique it's got
to be like that pine needles thing is so
dumb yeah and unimportant and not hard
like that's not hard to do like you know
I mean it's not like if you heard you'd
be like damn I could never do that like
you you know you can do that yeah yeah I
want you guys to meet Larry or you know
him he did all the pine needles I used
to have like when I was younger
um like crazy flexibility with my index
finger that's pretty good and I used to
be able to like lay it flat against my
hand oh wow you know and I and I
remember having the Illusion in my mind
that that in some way with this some
this will get me in the book in summer
right like this like I could I could go
like like lay flat it's really good um
I'll be that little trebuchet or I'll do
something yeah oh yeah yeah I'll work
for a castle or something but I was
actually I think as little as like young
boys we were just fascinated by this
remember like Robert Wadley the tallest
guy ever I was like yes I remember
seeing pictures of him he's like eight
eleven and then there was like the
fattest guy he was like I don't know
like 800 pounds so like anything that
was like this is a huge person I was
like that's yeah yeah that was him right
there
yeah he was from Illinois I think wasn't
he
was he
guessing but he seems like they would
they grow some long stuff out there they
sure do I would hate that man that's
that's the worst you would never want to
be everybody wants to be taller you
don't want to be that tall yeah he was
from Illinois Alton and was it eight
eight something was he like eight
um look at him with his family down
there on the left God yeah he was eight
foot eleven yeah oh 8 11.
if you think about that for a second
that this dude is nearly two feet taller
than Shaq wow two feet taller than him
that's so strange it would have been
yeah
to be that
yeah it seems like
I mean they're at they are at perfect
[__] height but it's still like
that's not what you want now that would
be interesting right to stand there and
have someone in there standing as well I
think it would feel very
in for like or just natural more natural
than somebody having to get down on
their knees or you having to lay down
like oh here I am here you are a girl
told me that she dated um oh uh very
well-known NBA player who is really tall
and um she's like yeah I could just blow
him standing up and I was like wow wow
that's got to be interesting I was like
everybody's proud of you yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was a great memory yeah yeah
think about what he's done and what
you've done it's pretty incredible yeah
yeah yeah he's got a couple rings and
you remember standing up to blow him
yeah there's definitely something about
it it would almost be like using a water
fountain that you didn't have to bend
over to use yeah exactly how nice would
that be we just go
and it just shoots right down your mouth
it'd be a lot Garth Brooks
what happened oh yeah I saw this Garth
Brooks is is he's gonna have Bud Light
at his bar Tommy yeah he's not gonna
he's refusing to ban it was
is right down here
I know it sounds corny I want it to be
the Chick-fil-A of Honky Tonks about his
new bar
um in Nashville I wanted to be a place
you feel safe in I want it to be a place
where you feel like there are manners
and people like one another hmm
and he added something there
and yes we're going sorry go down if you
go down he says and yes we're going to
serve every brand of beer we just are
it's not our decision to make well yeah
it is your decision to make yeah our
thing is this if you are into this house
love one another
if you're an [__] there are plenty of
other places on Lower Broadway oh wow
shots fired kind of yeah and there it is
Dylan Mulvaney they're gonna get in
there do you want to hear something that
I just heard yeah so I've talked about
him quite a bit about Garth Brooks I
know you guys have had some issues and I
found out this is dude I found out first
I got word
about a year ago
from like of like a hundred percent
reliable source sounds seems good
um that um I was like does he know and
they're like oh yeah yeah he knows
and I was like is he upset and they're
like he's just like doesn't get it like
doesn't know why you're talking about
him
I was like okay and then recently I
guess uh so he just blocked me on
Instagram oh
um and I was like uh oh it's finally it
finally blocked me you know uh and then
the person another person told me they
go yeah I heard this person said to me
that they heard from a reliable source
that when my name comes up to him
that he on his phone shows the video of
me playing basketball and falling and
goes Karma
Karma yeah
and I was like that's [__] pretty
amazing wow that a serial killer is
finding it in their heart to say karma
for the other person like this man has
I mean people are saying this man is
responsible for hundreds of missing
people and he's gonna
will say that it's karma well yes
somebody matched up I saw something
where they matched up like his tour
dates with missing people that's the
whole that's the premise of this idea
like people are like saying that I'm you
know like trolling the guy all I'm doing
is repeating what I have heard that
allegedly
his tour schedule aligns with like
dozens of missing persons yeah and so oh
well I mean it's just something that
like at least you would bring up and
talk it's like why do people talk about
UFOs you know why do why why have the
conversation about something in the like
well because people are saying that that
could be
a visitor from another planet right are
we not going to have even a conversation
about it right if if
75 people are missing and there's all in
cities that like he had just been in I
mean it's it's logical to say well okay
and look at him there are you telling me
I'm not you're telling me you've done
anything but that's the the the smile
and the stare of a guy who has never
done anything
illegal I don't know and how much land
he has too so much land
you wouldn't even know somebody who's
missing her if you'd put somebody
somewhere or not so much land he's the
Easter Bunny of bodies kind of oh yeah
and he's so here's the thing it's the
perfect you're so beloved that like oh
yeah we imagine the authorities too
they'd be like I'm sorry we were this is
crazy but we actually had a a dog that
can smell you know uh corpse and it was
on your property and it just went crazy
and then he'd be like I don't I'm Garth
Brooks yeah they're like yeah you're
right you're right sorry we're gonna
head on out yeah yeah we're thinking we
signed this for my son yeah exactly the
dog actually had a seizure on your
property
never had a smell like that in its life
but uh my son actually went missing on
your property in case he comes back when
you sign this sign this guitar yeah
appreciate you g
Onna That's it man I um
yeah do you think uh
has there been some has there been like
a really interesting guest that came out
I know Brad Pitt came out to one of your
shows which had been really insane that
was really insane that was really insane
is it almost scared is it almost a
is it a bummer meeting people that like
because once you meet him you kind of
have met him is there something about
that
um I think that probably can happen but
then there's people where you're like
that was awesome and um
they're either as cool or cooler than
your brain imagines yeah he was like
that he was rad he was he was really
cool and there was so much excitement
when when because they go he's coming
and then like security came to like
check out the place really yeah yeah
just like not a big team but just like
you know it's something I mean honestly
somebody in his position should have
that together because basically I asked
I was like so what do you do like he's
like well if I see that like a place is
a problem I'll just be like I don't
think you should come here yeah you know
like a club or as like a restaurant
where like this is not a good area or
and he's like you know he's just like
seeing where where things are and he's
like so I just I'm like his Advanced guy
it was like it was pretty low-key
honestly
but then they're like yo Brad just
parked everybody everybody was like that
and then he came in he couldn't have
been he just couldn't have been nicer
and like you know talked to introduce
those the funniest was one a very famous
person was like Hey I'm Brad and
everyone's like yeah I know you know
like but he was just super nice and I
thought a lot of times I've had other
notable people and what they do is they
um they they they leave during something
you know like famous people go like they
just kind of disappear
he stayed the whole show came back after
the show
um he was enjoying it he enjoyed it and
then um that was it was a lot of fun
then uh
I ran into well I ended up befriending
Jason Momoa Aquaman oh yeah in New
Zealand wow and that was really fun and
I hung out with him for another day swim
or anything no we we went to a bar and
we hung out with like I don't know a
group for like 10 hours dang but he
couldn't have been like he's a real down
to earth guy yeah we met we met at the
hotel gym no that's cool he was like
I'll crouched down you make you look
taller I was like cool man
oh you look pretty happy right it was
fun we had we had a fun time
um
yeah you know and then Izzy came out in
Auckland too he I feel like he comes in
he's a really special guy he's a he's a
cool uh man there's something really
interesting about him there's something
really amazing about new zealanders in
general there is there is yeah and I
think
he has a really
it's a Fighters are fascinating to sign
up for that lifestyle you know what I
mean like yeah to be like I'm gonna I'm
gonna do battle for a living
that was two tour that was like in 2019
but yeah he he came again in this most
recent tour and um I just uh
I just enjoy the guy's energy you know
just being around 100 just being around
him and very inspirational whether he
wins or loses he's very inspirational a
lot of these Fighters are like that
there's something about a lot of them
whether they win or lose because you
just value so much that they even could
do it because they're they're actually
really putting it's it's you know what
it is like inherently human beings we
respect stakes and if you're a fighter
the stakes are very clear like you're
you're putting your your physical body
on the line yeah to to win or lose and
so everybody we we just respect the fact
that like you're gonna like punch and
kick and like you know to your [__]
face and like this this could have like
real lasting effects so we just respect
it so much but I like that dude's energy
um and and I do find it inspiring to be
around them I like him a lot yeah yeah
there's something real special about him
yeah
um
trying to think about anything else I
wanted to ask you Zach anything coming
ahead
um
for watching this video this like short
guy
standing up to these dudes in a parking
garage what do you think
this is a tough guy right here uh oh
somebody's black be careful
right
get up out of here bro get in the corner
go could be on his dumb ass [__]
security trying to say he been trying to
save you God bless you man get in your
car and get up out of here man God bless
you
God bless you man just go ahead and get
in the car and make it home safe man
good he feels right now that's so good
[__] Lee syat is like I [__] took
this [__] down make it home safe buddy
oh my God how is there not a call to a
welfare line can I tell you something
too because I love Joey Diaz but he was
actually like a virus to that man like
do you know what has happened to Lee
since party he lost 150 pounds not an
exaggeration
150 pounds he's like free of Joey like
he just totally has like blossomed look
at him oh my god dude he looks oh yeah
he looks good he looks exactly like the
guy we just saw in the last video dude
uh holy [__] look at him congrats to Lee
yeah Joe even like you're not doing well
enough Lee you need another couple 2 000
milligrams dude at least remember they
were wearing floaties I'd never seen
somebody so high
and here's the thing Lee couldn't say
anything so he would be like I'd be like
yeah I was like are you all right he's
like he could let he forget to like
click he would just sit there snoring
sitting down like
like snoring in his seat and then Joey's
like look at this [__] idiot he's
like you know what he does all day he
watches Sports Center I hear his phone
goes
get your [__] [__] together I'm like
you are crippling this man
SportsCenter is all he can handle he's
working an Enterprise rental houses
he's [__] doing good
wow yeah it'd be there should be a
documentary one day made on Joey and Lee
and like a coming back together park by
a lake is this them recently that might
be an old picture it was nothing like
those two they were like uh who was a
better name a better comedy what this is
like though this is like this is like
the um the the guy on the left Lee gets
locked up in prison with the veteran you
know the guy that's been locked up
that's what the relationship was like is
what you're going to do all right you
stay away from the blacks you mind your
business you shower when I shower and
like and then you eat this [__] yeah
just like in another dimension yeah
brother 84 ounces of uh Alfredo so he
would melt his brain unreal he would
melt his brain dude what was the time
one of my favorite times ever when I got
there there was look at that [__]
pillow somebody made have you done have
you seen the one have you seen the one
on uh um where Lee
is us like he falls asleep alone on
on the show yeah I think he's like he's
working it and then he's like and he
comes to he's like oh [__] like he just
it's it's I've watched it he's so
[__] high so good that he falls
asleep and wakes himself up and he's
like I don't even know what's happening
man I don't know if he's like he's
streaming or something like on Twitch I
don't know what but it's on YouTube and
it's it is it's so amazing it's like Lee
the best one time I went in and there
was a squeal in the headphones when I
went in yeah I was like Lee there's some
feedback or something by the end two and
a half hours later this Lee was like
this
he was the squeal yeah and we had gone
full [__] Circle yeah kicked that
mulee look he look look and listen
listen to the audio
he's broadcasting right now
oh damn dude
[Laughter]
get out of his mind dude
that's a good place and that's just that
is just if Joey is really close to you
this happens to you oh yeah well he
drugged me yeah he he [__] tricked me
and he's done it a couple times but the
worst one was in when I was in Miami and
he told me I was taking a 10.
and it just [__] it ruined two days
in my life right like two days of my
life
and
I I mean I was like just
I mean I was I was crying and [__] oh
yeah I was on a flight with him oh and
he's like oh you need you need a you
need a baby Xanax right now before he
goes out I'm like I don't think this is
the [__] foreign
and I go dude and when I finally like
recovered I called her I was like what
the [__] dude he goes you needed it I go
I needed what you needed a reset and I
go why did I need one he's like it's
good for you I I saw what was happening
like this kind of thing always like that
what was happening he's like nah you
know you were getting you know a little
it's good now now you're ready to go I'm
like ready to go where am I going
yeah I'm at a gray house yeah man I'm I
was fine he was like no no no I did you
it was fun I go for who
he is dude he's the best salesman bro
yeah he just says like these little and
he says it with his like little phrase
it was great yeah yeah and you're like
that's yeah I love you buddy yeah and
you're like that yeah you get back to
chopping up vinegar and carrots you're
like the [__] are you talking about man
what about that Owen Benjamin all these
[__] lost his mind huh she'll say
[__] like that and then [__] just
disappear dude unrest
on [__] real dude
look if that doesn't if that doesn't do
it I don't know what it does uh Tom
Segura thanks for hanging out with us
man yeah it was a lot of fun man yeah
same here dude I'd love to come back on
uh on a two bears sometime let's do it
let's do it all right thank you so much
man all right buddy thank you nah I'm
just floating on the breeze
[Music]
gonna take